so we are in a full dystopia at this
point in time yesterday I already told
you Donald Trump went to the Rose Garden
he gave an authoritarian nightmare of a
speech where he says he will fight
governor's by deploying the military to
enforce the law in their states the
legal fight is Posse Comitatus Act
versus insurrection act we've already
talked about that certainly at its face
the idea that we need to fight protests
about law enforcement using too much
force by scaling up the amount of force
used by law enforcement that's crazy
we've already talked about that but then
we get into the propaganda of this
Donald Trump had protesters tear gassed
and dispersed with horses to clear the
way for Donald Trump to walk to st.
John's Church in Washington DC and be
photographed holding up a Bible he was
asked mr. president is that your Bible
and he said it is a Bible of course it's
not Trump's Bible Trump is not religious
this is merely pandering in front of the
church this was done in a completely
just sickening obvious brazen attempt to
propagandize but in order to get over
there here is video of the protesters
and here you will hear the bangs going
off you will see the gas start to rise
hey he takes the propaganda seriously
for sure
here are members of the press being
shooed away as Donald Trump walks over
to the Cathedral and then hears an
overhead view of the entire crowd being
aggressively dispersed including with
tear gas because the leader Trump must
get to the church to hold someone's
Bible bringing out the horses you're
gonna hear some of the flashbangs at the
start of this video
and so then here is Donald Trump calling
over his press secretary and a couple of
others and standing there and sort of it
at some point Trump says okay the
propaganda event is over and this is one
of the most Awkward video clips I've
seen in a long time
thank you very much
the greatest country in the world thank
you very much everybody keep it nice and
safe
so everybody there in that photo-op
people who should be people who should
be unemployed come January if we do our
job in November now by the way just one
other thing from earlier here was
Trump's Rose Garden statement just
minutes before walking over to st.
John's having protesters tear gassed and
dispersed with horses you can hear
explosions going on in the background
while Trump is speaking he will not have
died in vain but we cannot allow the
righteous cries of peaceful protesters
to be drowned out by an angry mob the
biggest victims of the riot that is not
thunder you are hearing my friends those
are flash bangs going off to disperse
protesters in advance of Trump walking
over to st. John's Cathedral this is
where we are it's incredible how far we
have fallen since that horrible day
November of 2016 and I've been you know
I've been talking about hyper
normalization I've been talking about
desensitization it happens a little bit
at a time but now when you go back and
think of that day when Donald Trump was
inaugurated we have fallen so so far now
if you need a reminder of how not
religious Trump is if you needed a
reminder of how the Bible and the church
are just props for the president
remember this video for the camp from
the campaign where Donald Trump making
it abundantly clear he doesn't know a
damn thing about the Bible he doesn't
care about the Bible
you mentioned the Bible you've been
talking about how it's your favorite
book and you said I think last night in
Iowa some people are surprised that you
say that I'm wondering what one or two
of your most favored Bible verses are I
wouldn't want to get into it because to
me that's very personal you know when I
talk about the Bible is very personal so
I don't want to get into really I don't
want to get into it means a lot to you
that you think about ersite the Bible
means a lot to me but I don't want to
get into specifics even decide a verse
you know like I don't want to do that
Old Testament guy our new Testament
probably equal I think it's just an
incredible the whole Bible is an
incredible I joke very much so they
always hold up the order that the I say
my second favorite book of all time but
I just think the Bible is just something
very special this has to stop this has
to stop for our sake it has to stop for
the world's sake it has to stop for our
futures sake Trump doesn't even attend
church it's not even his Bible
aggressively and violently dispersing
peaceful protestors with horses and
flashbangs
and tear gas so that he could hold up
someone's Bible and take advantage of
just a disgusting I mean this is this is
like Soviet style North Korea style
propaganda that Donald Trump is brazenly
crafting in front of our very eyes and
we have to end it we have to end it let
me know your thoughts about all of this
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman thrilled to
see more and more folks listening to the
daily audio podcast of the show if you
watch on YouTube you may not know that
you can go on iTunes or stitcher or
Google Play podcast whatever you want
and get our daily audio podcast do it
it's a great way to consume the show in
addition to the YouTube clips let me
know your thoughts about this propaganda
on Twitter at D Pakman and we'll be
right back